here are the three signs and maybe time
to cut off a friend number one how do
they react when you share exciting news
with them are they genuinely happy for
you do they celebrate with you or are
they envious and jealous of you if
they're bringing negativity when you are
sharing positive news it may be time to
kick them out of your life number two do
they ask about you or are they only
absorbed in themselves relationships are
a two-way street and if it's only one
way if it's only you caring about them
that can lead to a very draining
negative toxic relationship number three
do you feel like your most authentic
self around them if you have to be fake
when you're around your friends then
those are fake friends and you deserve
better the reality is that as you grow
you may have to cut off some friends
that aren't growing too if you have had
to cut somebody off let me know in the
comments below